for you man like uh you obviously have
always had an ear for your talent before
it pops right like who are you just a
fan of right now
that you're just like yo from Far like
maybe not even necessarily someone you
got a relationship with what I'm a fan
of right now you mean like an artist
yeah just an artist yeah yeah of a
comment on just like regular artists
anybody
damn oh I'm a fan of right now
[Music]
um
damn who really rapping like that right
now oh I'm just draw we'll be driving I
mean this to myself man like let me see
who I'm trying to think about upcoming I
like ice spice I ain't gonna care I
spice I like ice but that's funny
because she a girl like he picked a girl
but [__] she knew though she popping I
like what she doing she got some records
on gang like which I found about her
like before like like before she got
popping off and [__] like that I was
talking to her and her [__] just took
off so I'm like damn like you feel me I
like seeing like [__] like that like
[__] just be like you know what
I'm saying under the radar and then just
take off you feel me I like saying [__]
like that would you work with ice spice
yeah yeah send the DM try to make it
happen we all right we be talking I'll
be talking to her shout out to ice but
she cool
she's on fire I think she's the most
streamed artist like the last month or
so or something it's kind of crazy yeah
I mean I like I like what she's doing
for sure uh
uh what about the last what's the last
album that you love that dropped
besides Soldier season which is out now
by the way it has album
um that I like that drop probably was
like um
probably was like it's a couple of them
probably was like uh Drake and 21 Savage
[__] great album and then um
I like that single he dropped too that
searching search engine whatever search
and rescue that [__] hard as [__] Yadi
Yadi new [__] hard what's that new
yachty single strike Striker yeah have
you did you listen to yachty's rock
album
did you listen to that I mean that's the
album you listen to you eat shrooms and
listen to that [__] I mean I ain't
really get to tap all the way into it I
heard like some of it I just feel like
he just being different and that's
that's what keep the culture going
forward right [__] always try putting
it inside a box you know what I'm saying
so will we ever get the and I might be
it might already be up but the the Drake
We Made It freestyle will that ever make
it to dsps
um [__] yeah yeah eventually
like a legendary record I just like
surprised like I have to go on YouTube
to listen to it ordapiff.com YouTube
SoundCloud I forgot what happened with
that record man we supposed to shot a
video all this type of [__] but you guys
shout out to Drake though yeah you guys
are good yeah he doing his thing man I'm
doing my thing and you know that's
another [__] I'm proud of too he came a
long way too that's funny I don't watch
a lot of careers come a long way bro
came a long way he does also say a lot
that you figured out a way to be
relevant no matter what in the last
since wait you came out in 07 yeah so
like since 2007 we're talking about 16
years yeah that was the whole that was
the whole idea though from the start
cast you've been asked you've been
famous as long as you've like because if
you think about it you became famous
when you were 16 or 15. yeah 16. so
you've been famous now as long as you
were alive
before you were famous
fifty percent of your life you've been
living
both sides you know what I'm saying but
I just feel like I always wanted that
longevity you know what I'm saying you
know when I first came out that's gonna
be one hit wonder and then I had to come
with another hit then I had to come with
another hit kiss me through the phone
it's like your biggest record on Spotify
too yeah so but longevity that's the key
that's the key
[Applause]
yeah I was just because I was listening
to your new album and now I just I was
like man let me look at this [__]
because I'd be forgetting how many
records you got
I'm like Jesus Christ I've just I saw a
bird walk I was like I wonder what would
happen if birdwalk came out when Tick
Tock was popping oh damn I want a little
bit like a tick tock would Crank that
would came oh my God it's [__] insane
you still got [__] you got 40 year
olds cranking that you know hands and
weddings and stuff oh for sure every
wedding is playing Crank that I don't
care how white and old or random it is
crank that's getting played there's like
a few hip-hop songs that get played in
every way Flo Rida's low with T-Pain
Crank that those are the only two I got
maybe some sort of Nelly ride with me or
something
that's good man like that love is crazy
like that support that that just to see
people still doing that for that record
that was a crazy record okay you have
because I feel like you've lived the
type of life that eventually will get
made into a Netflix series
or like uh
AMC show or something or FX who would
you have play you
and use not an option
um right now yeah I mean yeah I mean I
don't know if you can't predict future
actors yeah right now um
like Michael B Jordan or something like
that Michael B Jordan that Soldier Boy
you know I don't know that he read who
else to lose so he's kind of yoke your
skinny guy I know that's a fact so he's
saying like who that's what I'm saying
we're actually there's not many actors
out there that really just look like me
Jordan a soldier would be pretty wild
who who really look like me like that
that's kind of who could pull it off
like I would have to play myself you
would have to play yourself I gotta be
me nobody can't be Draco
okay would the the your famous Vlad
story
is that going to be in the show hell
yeah but it ain't gonna be no story it's
gonna be the real [__] you know what I'm
saying